[Musique]
c'est quoi ce sont là les mecs
j'aime bien oui ça met du shérif merci
d'être avec nous rouler dans ces
conditions les chauffards sur une petite
danse du des stress à 18h45 jusqu'à 20
heures qu'est ce qui va se passer on
discute médias vous êtes contents vous
rentrez chez vous n'êtes pas pays
ensuite après derrière à prendre ou à
laisser
[Musique]
allez donc cyril je suis désolé pour
vous mais ce soir vous aurez rien en
tout cas vous vous joignez c'est
pourquoi je vous aime vous avez le don
de mettre l'ambiance
chérie on est ensemble jusqu'à 20h
cadeaux attendu après c'est à prendre ou
à laisser
jours après qu'il y aura un coût
pauvreté show juillet ça suffit excusez
moi vous regardez l'émission qui souffre
est en train de faire là ça dans un
faire un barbecue manger des bières bien
souvent regardé des nations
[Musique]
chaud chaud chaud
je rappelle que nous verrons notre salle
tropicale au moins quatre avec tous les
tubes des tropiques tester mois pour
savoir sur le direct parce que c'est un
jour férié à plein de gens qui me
ils sont pas on dirait que la télé c'est
magouille et compagnie ouais ça c'était
pourri trop de fric j'en ai ras l'afutt
vite mélenchon s'appelle je m'appelle
théo je m'appelle théo théo tetrobot t
au t3
j'attends j'attends j'attends d'abord la
douleur
alors comment va se passer la relance là
après cette petite crise face à une
grosse clé je pense que ça va être très
compliqué très compliqué alors qu'est ce
que tu me dis moi tu lui dois tout hier
il m'a dit pareil elle m'a dit c'est
compliqué je dis oui demande à fixer des
règles et mahdi mohamed a beau fixe et
des règles d'accès comme on était
d'accord final l épique et j'ai un rêve
qui se réalise pour moi
lundi matin parce que j'ai mon
animateurs un de mes animateurs radio
préférée des animateurs préférés et
j'aime beaucoup corée mais j'aime
également énormément d'histoires et pour
moi voilà le plus grand animal terre
radio de tous les temps qui m'a proposé
de venir faire le morning avec lui de 6h
à 9h lundi sur skyrock
je suis comme un ouf avec toute sa bande
bien sûr et je vais faire tout le
morning avec eux mon franck gastambide à
moi mon beau gosse ça sert et le bleu
comme ça qu'est ce que ça vous va bien
mais c'est un bleu lagon sera je sois au
bleu des mers du sud
je sais pas ou bien c'est un bleu tout
coup d'être le tout court merci laetitia
notre bavard qui veut rentrer dans
toutes les
elle n'a rien à voir avec roche mif les
femmes pouvaient participer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors soit en tout cas les deux regardez
en rouge et bleu comme ça j'ai
l'impression d'avoir baby foot devant
moi on essaie de s'en sortir à chaque
fois oui bon gars mais vous allez marié
un aussi mauvais non célibataires
d'accord en fait j'ai compris dans cette
émission tous les mecs sont célibataires
et toutes les filles son couple voilà
j'ai confiance en mon pays la patrie le
jour de gloire est arrivé alors là il ya
des gens qui arrivent sur ces villas
témoins quelques maquettes ya un mec sur
un siège et sait pas qui fait bien une
meuf elle va faire atterrir un avion
vous allez décider en bois en bouteille
de ketchup
on comprend pas voilà il ya un gars
pourquoi delà une punk ragga de 10
et pourquoi y en avoir 16 et ben voilà
c'est ça qui fait l'émission est
pourquoi ils sont dans un jardin
botanique joue apple chez novell notre
salle tropicale au moins quatre oui oui
sa devise c'est la panse oui oui il
apprend ce qu'est ce que tu veux
oui la pince
ouais j'ai envie
[Musique]
c'était le banquet je dois y aller petit
à prendre ou à laisser
c'est parti c'est que du kif salue les
chéris j'y vois on vous regarde
[Musique]